each event each of the hostings has
started with a six minute introduction
statement from the three candidates Then
followed by the Q a
questions taken from the four no
Advanced questions and every question
has to be put to all three candidates so
bear that in mind when you ask a
question it's got to be a question
capable of being answered by all three
candidates
I have mentioned to the candidates that
this venue used to be a slaughterhouse
but it should be a well conducted
I mean
and those from Edinburgh will know that
to be true
so without any further Ado if we can go
straight to the introductory statements
and I'll hand over to Ash
well thank you very much and good
evening and it's wonderful to see so
many smiling faces at this event this
evening and so this is the seventh
hosting that we're doing I think we're
getting um towards the end now but it's
lovely to be in Edinburgh this evening
I know that some people have been
listening to the online you know the
live streams
um and I have been talking about the the
yes campaign and I was asking people to
think about how they felt on the morning
after the referendum when we all woke up
to find the result or if we'd been up
all night like I had to let that result
sink in and then I was talking about the
yes campaign but the reason I was doing
that is I was trying to sort of Connect
into that feeling that we all had at the
time of how we'd all work together and
um working for a better Scotland and
that real sense of optimism and
confidence and hope in Scotland and
being Scottish and working towards that
better Scotland and I'm in this contest
because I want to get independence and I
want to get it sooner rather than later
so thank you
so
um when I was in the S campaign I was
just really struck by that sense of
everyone working together
and I really enjoyed that and I want us
to get back to that since
um now so but I think at the moment
we've there's a sense for me and I don't
know if other people share this but that
we're Treading Water a bit certainly in
terms of the progress towards either a
referendum or the progress towards
independence and you'll know if you
um do any swimming that if you tread
water for a really long time eventually
you're going to tire out and you'll be
swept away so I'm suggesting that
actually what we need to do is to stop
treading water and we need to we need to
move forward we need to change that
direction so I think we need to relight
the fires of the yes campaign right
across Scotland
we need to heal the rest in our own
party we need to unite with a wider
movement Inspire and lead them because I
think that's the way we're going to get
to Independence only if we all work
together as one towards that better
Scotland
so my suggestion for this is that we set
up an independence convention so the
idea behind that is that is where
everyone that's interested in an
independent Scotland can work together
so Civil Society other pro-endy parties
think tanks academics businesses
everyone all in together and I haven't
been waiting to do that I've already
been reaching out to various different
organizations across the yes landscape
to talk to them and to see what the
um the feeling is on that and many of
them are really excited to be involved
and glad to be considered so I think
that's that's working well so far and
then my other suggestion is that we set
up an independence commission so the
idea behind this is that rather than
waiting until we become independent that
we actually start working on the
infrastructure the planning the
preparation for all the infrastructure
that we're going to need to be an
independent country and then as part of
that we communicate the progress that's
being made on that to the public so that
they're able to see that and so that
they're going to have confidence that we
have that infrastructure which will
build confidence and allow them to feel
safe and choosing to vote for
Independence
so as first Minister I would see my role
as concentrating on the priorities of
the people of Scotland and so that would
be things like the NHS the cost of
living crisis businesses the environment
our schools education and so on and I
intend to put the absolute best people
into those top tough jobs and intend to
give them the full freedom to do
whatever they think needs to be done
and I think we need to be really
transparent really accountable that's
how we build trust in government and
with that trust in government we can
move forward towards independence
because that trust builds confidence as
well
and I'm suggesting that we instead of
being passive that we take control of
this process towards independence
ourselves so I'm calling it the voter
empowerment mechanism and it's a
permanent mechanism that cheats each and
every election as an opportunity for the
people of Scotland to express their
views it gives the power back to the
people of Scotland and lets them tell us
when it's time for Scotland to become an
independent country
so I'm happy to talk more about that
this evening but I just want to leave
you with this that if you pick me to be
your leader I will make the hard choices
I'll make the tough decisions and I'll
be absolutely and utterly Relentless
until we get to the point where
Scotland's future is finally in
Scotland's hands
foreign
thanks very much I should have mentioned
if anyone's taking photographs it should
only be of the candidates and not of
other people in the audience and also I
think if if we're in Hamza and Keith
speak if they can stay a little bit to
the side so you're going to do it
outside just so we don't obscure the um
signing person over to you Hamza as much
uh can you hear me okay good evening
Edinburgh
uh thanks for uh well thanks for that
warm welcome particularly given that
you're letting a Ouija speak to you uh
tonight that's very cute that just lost
me half the votes in the room I know
listen uh genuinely though it's a real
pleasure uh to be here with you and can
I start actually by paying tribute to my
two colleagues as well because we have
been doing hustings after hustings uh
and uh we're still going which is not
bad at all so we've got a few more to go
and I think everybody on this stage
deserves a round of applause
um can I see and start with a couple of
promises to you before I give you what
will be a bit of the pitch so for me
first and foremost a promise that my
campaign and I in particular we're going
to keep this really positive there's a
really positive message a positive
vision and we're not going to get into
mud slinging or personal attacks because
the only people that benefit from that
are opposition let's be honest the only
people who benefit from that are are all
positions so let's from my team
absolutely keep it positive let's
challenge each other of course we've got
different ideas in this stage let's be
robust about that let's be robust about
policy and the second promise I'm going
to make you is I'm not going to talk
down the record of our SMP government
because we have achieved so much
we have achieved so much as the
government and again the only people are
going to benefit from that are
opposition when it's not going to help
us to deliver Independence because our
record's a good one and I've been proud
to be part of the s p government for 10
and a half years proud I would hope to
one day be able to build upon the Legacy
that Nicola and John have left us that's
a legacy that's helped us to deliver the
baby box so every child in Scotland gets
the best start in life uh it's uh it's a
it's a record that's seen us deliver
over a hundred thousand affordable homes
it's a record that's seen us commit to
free personal care it's a record that's
seen US expand child care to record
levels look at when in much better days
of course with SMP controlled Edinburgh
city council a thousand one thousand one
one hundred affordable energy efficient
homes every single year you build eight
new schools when Adam McPhee and the SNP
team were in charge of the council here
in Edison a really good record so why me
that's the question you've got to ask
yourself out of the three candidates who
are you going to choose why me well I
think for a few reasons first and
foremost
to win independence we've got to inspire
people you know Westminster has many
many feelings the cost of living crisis
that has seen so much damage to so many
people in Scotland the fact that in
Scotland a country that's energy rich
but our people are feel poor what a
disgrace
the fact that we have a prime minister
who extols the virtues of the Northern
Ireland protocol but denies that same
democracy that same opportunity to
Scotland
but
but despite all those feelings we can't
rely on people to vote for Independence
because of westminster's feelings we've
got to give them a reason to vote for
Independence and that's the vision I
believe I've got the ability to reach
across the Divide to build our support
to inspire people with a vision why do I
want independence I want independence
not to reduce child poverty or poverty I
want to eradicate poverty I want the
powers of Independence because I want to
unleash our potential in the green
energy sector I want independence
because I know that we can unleash this
country's full potential and there's so
much more we can say and we will see
throughout the course of this debate but
we have to give people a positive reason
of vision why should you vote for
Independence because I promise you
if we do that if we grow that consistent
majority support for Independence
Independence becomes inevitable we'll
talk about the process and again we'll
get into plenty of discussion throughout
this about process but our opponents are
desperate they're desperate for us to
stay in this Quagmire process do you
think talk of sex and thirties and de
facto referendums inspire people out
there of course they don't it's the
vision for Independence that inspires
second reason I hope you'll consider
giving me your first choice is I've got
the experience 10 and a half years of
doing some of the toughest jobs in
government transport Justice health and
yep there's challenges in each of those
roles challenges in the Health Service
tell you what those challenges will be
in a hell of a lot more difficult if our
NHS workers went on strike and I'm
really really pleased that Scotland
Remains the only part of the United
Kingdom we're not a single NHS worker
has gone on strike not because of Good
Fortune not because of coincidence but
because I've had the ability to reach
across the Divide to bring our trade
unions closer to us to make sure we find
compromise and that's not difficult for
me because I'm a trade unionist at heart
so I've got no problem at doing all of
that so that's the second reason
for me the third reason is exceptionally
important that if I am the next leader
of the SNP I want us to get out there
and restart the yes campaign as soon as
we possibly can not just not just uh the
SNP but making sure the entire Movement
we take with us that Civic LED Grass
Roots movement I'm not just gonna I
don't want to just be your first
Minister I want to be your first
activist I want to stand alongside every
single one of you chapping those doors
pounding those Pavements looking into
the whites of people's eyes to inspire
them to vote for Independence so we need
good governance we need to restart the
yes campaign and we need to inspire
people to vote for Independence and I
hope for all those reasons and all the
reasons you're here tonight that you'll
consider giving me your first choice
thank you so much
thank you thank you very much I'm Kate
well good evening
it's fabulous to join you tonight as a
good Highlander I've got no skin in the
game between Glasgow and Edinburgh so
we're hopefully you'll you'll accept me
tonight but it's wonderful to be able to
join you as some of you know just about
six or seven months ago I had a little
baby girl so the bags under my eyes are
all to do with the fact that I go home
from things like this and she decides
it's play time and then I start work the
next day having not slept
but it's been absolutely wonderful to
come back from maternity leave back into
these hostings as grueling as the
schedule has been over the last few
weeks it's been wonderful to get round
the country and meet with SMP activists
across Scotland because what it feels
like is coming home what it feels like
is coming back to a family because in
every part of Scotland I've had the
pleasure and the privilege of
campaigning on doorsteps and looking
back at the smps track record looking
back at the last 16 years of of winning
elections in the last 100 years or so of
campaigning the reason that we are where
we are today the reason that we've had
successive
governments in power in Hollywood and
successive election results when it
comes to Westminster is because we're a
team
because wherever anything else we agree
or disagree on we agree on this goal
that Scotland should be a sovereign
independent Free Nation
and
and the reason we should be a sovereign
independent free nation is not just
because we believe in Independence but
we we believe in Independence as a means
to an end and for me that end is poverty
I was in Sterling today I was in Rat
block today meeting with families and
households in an area where there's high
levels of poverty and the stories that
you hear are devastating and one of the
guys I was speaking to uh just before I
before I arrived he had bumped into one
of the families that was making use of
of their food bank and he said I'm off
to meet Kate Forbes and he said who
I didn't take the offense and he said
she's going to be first Minister and the
lady said who's that what's that
and the point I'm making is for that
family for that individual the issues of
just getting by every day are of such
Monumental significance that they need
to know their politicians care not just
about the figures the stats and the
abstract arguments they care about
putting food in those kids bellies they
care about ensuring that no child in
Scotland goes to bed hungry cold or
unloved and as we meet tonight that our
one in four children in poverty so when
it comes to Independence when I talk
about my wee girl my wee seven month old
girl Independence is a means to an end
and the stakes could not be higher
because until we are independent we will
keep on mitigating the worst decisions
that are being made by the UK government
we will continue to make sure our money
goes as far as it possibly can but it
will be never enough to eradicate the
scourge of poverty which has no place in
modern Scotland
[Applause]
and if Independence is critical so also
is the continued success of the SMP
winning elections so that we can use a
Devolution to resolve those issues of
poverty and that's why when I take a
step back and look at our success we've
been successful because we're a team
we're United with a goal we've been
successful because we've got a solid
record of earning the trust of the
Scottish people that come what me we
will never let them down and the third
reason we've been successful is because
we listen
we listen when brexit came we listened
and we stood up for Scotland when covid
came we listened and we stood up for
Scotland we're in the teeth of a cost of
living crisis that means families across
Scotland do not know how to pay next
month's energy bills we need to listen
we need to adapt and if we care about
continuing to win elections as we shoot
and ultimately delivering Independence
it matters that now again we are
listening to the people
so what do I offer in this contest well
this is what I offer first of all is the
importance of recognizing that for us to
win independence it's not enough to just
persuade those who are already persuaded
because we know all of us in this room
all of us in the SMP all of us in the
YES Movement were already persuaded
but I am convinced because I'm convinced
of the arguments for Independence I am
convinced we can persuade more people to
support Independence and grow that
support but it will take someone who can
reach across the Divide who can listen
who can deliver when it comes to
Independence and Paul after Paul at the
moment is showing that it really matters
for us to win independence that we have
a leader that can reach out to no voters
now it might seem strange that I'm
standing up in front of you talking
about no voters because we're all yes
voters but all of us want independence
more than anything else and that will
come when we persuade people and the
other two reasons are this
that when it comes to Devolution I don't
think it is enough to just defend
Evolution although that's really
important I think we need to make
Devolution work as much as possible for
the people of Scotland and we've been
making it work for the last 15 years but
right now when it comes to the cost of
living our public services or economy we
need to listen once again to what people
are saying and adapt and deliver and the
last thing
what else do I bring when it comes to
this contest I bring a renewed Vision a
willingness to re-energize our party and
ensure its members that are running the
show members that are influencing policy
and ensuring that this is a Grassroots
organization where the leader listens to
the members and its members that build
policy from the Grassroots up that's
important if we believe in democracy it
needs to start with our party and I
think that ultimately that's how we
persuade people of the value of
Independence because our membership is
reflective of the Scottish public so on
that I'm going to stop but I take you
back to why the stakes are high the
stakes are high because one in four
children are living in poverty tonight
we can't let that happen every day that
we are not independent is one day too
many and the faster we're independent
and the faster we end poverty the better
thank you
okay when I want to questions the usual
way of showing you want to speak or try
and be as as Fair as it can be so um
just to go right to the back first of
all the lady with the space Sorry yep
yeah
hi there Sarah Chung from Enbridge
Central Branch
I work in the financial services
industry and I recently just got married
to a registered mental health nurse we
joined the SMP as we believe in a fair
and an independent equal Scotland that
is Richard Greener and gets rid of
westminster's arcade rule
we are TR but we are troubled by the
fact that our marriage is seen as
something lesser now I know there are
going to be people in this room who will
roll their eyes and on this on the
stream who will go oh my God another
question on lgbtq plus let's focus on
Independence
but NHS heck I even got shouted at on
the zoom chat but how can we believe in
your vision of Independence even though
we work and form a significant part of
these areas you speak about
is it not possible for us to speak about
independence and the NHS and other
topics without making us feel like
second class and I understand that we
are a family but sometimes especially in
the Chinese culture in my culture we
need a whole family to account so we
don't lose face
foreign
first of all is Hamza
can we just make sure that the
individual is okay uh Sarah said okay
yeah thumbs up okay well thanks for
asking that question
um and and speaking so passionately
about it look I don't I don't take the
view at all that we should only talk
about
certain issues and not talk about others
all these issues are really important
dealing with the NHS we'll get on to
that I'm certain dealing with the issues
around the economy and the well-being
economy in particular but equality of
course is important look I've lived my
entire life in this country uh Sarah
much like you as a minority in this
country and my rights don't exist in
some sort of vacuum my rights have
interdependent on everybody else's
rights my rights are your rights your
rights are my rights and if we let
somebody else's rights come under attack
they'll be my rights next so so
important that whoever is the leader of
the SNP and therefore the first minister
of Scotland that everybody everybody can
look that person in the eye and
genuinely believe that their lifestyle
will not be judged to be morally
inferior to theirs and I can give you an
absolute promise an absolute commitment
that I won't just tolerate to you but I
will celebrate
that whatever lifestyle you have however
you choose to live your life will be one
where I don't just protect your rights I
Advance them as far as I possibly can
and for me I don't want to just protect
them under Devolution with Independence
I want your rights to be in a written
Constitution and so they can be
protected and being no doubt whatsoever
attack rights up under attack if you
believe that they're not just look at
what happened in Roe versus Wade In
America people are coming after race
there's a culture war going on we all
know that so it's exceptionally
important that whoever is the next
leader of the SNP the next first
Minister that all of our communities in
Scotland
feel that they are protected they're
valued and they're celebrated and this
is important in its own right but to be
frank is also important when it comes to
delivering Independence because it's
important of course to reach out to no
voters it's important to bring people
towards our cause it's also important we
don't lose the support that we have the
important base that we have of support
and my belief and I'll end on this point
my belief is that is our Progressive
agenda that has won US election after
election after election support made us
the dominant
political force in Scotland and if we
roll back on any of that then we can
reach out to all the no voters we want
but we will lose that support that has
made us so so popular so I give you an
absolute end of this point I'll give you
an unequivocal commitment that if I am
the next leader of the SNP Scotland's
next first Minister whoever you are
whatever your lifestyle know that I will
not just protect your rights but at
every time I will defend them and where
possible Advance them to
[Applause]
a new kit great thanks very much and
thanks Sarah for asking the question
because I was conscious of you asking
the question on the zoom and it didn't
get put to us so I'm glad that you had
the opportunity to ask that tonight
Scotland's diversity is what makes us
the the beautiful Rich vibrant place
that we call home and Scotland I think
has made huge strides when it comes to
tolerance when it comes to liberalism
but that will only last if it is a place
where minorities all minorities
including LGBT minorities feel safe and
secure and it's certainly my honest
pledge that I for as long as I am first
minister or for as long as I'm in
politics that I will uphold the legal
protections and the rights that exist
for every Scot in Scotland whether they
are male female Gay Street or trans and
right now when it comes to minority
rights
the important part of being in a liberal
plural society is that one minority can
say to another I defend your right and
or your rights in the hope that you will
defend my rights and that is how a
healthy democracy works the closest
example I have had of doing that is when
it comes to budgets so ultimately
underpinning all of the Scottish
government's decisions
laws legislation the progress that's
been made over the last few years
underpinning all of that is the
financial decisions and in successive
budgets we have pooped fairness at the
very heart I've put fairness at the very
heart of those budgets to ensure that
those budgets are delivering it for all
of Scotland but have a particular focus
on supporting Scotland's minority groups
including LGBT groups so that's the
approach I've taken to budgets which you
may think it's not as important as being
first Minister you can't be first
Minister for that it's old budget and
that's the approach that I would take to
being first Minister thanks
foreign
yeah so I'm a lifelong committed
Progressive and I want everyone to be
able to live there best most authentic
lives in peace dignity and safety and if
I'd been in the parliament at the time
when we voted on equal marriage I would
have voted for it and I would have been
glad to vote for it in fact a few years
ago I was invited to the wedding of some
friends and activists of mine Jean and
Elaine and it was a very moving wedding
actually and the couple had been
together for I think over 20 years maybe
nearly towards 30 years and they hadn't
been able to get married until a few
years ago so it was wonderful to be able
to celebrate that um fantastic day with
them so as first Minister I will work to
protect and enhance everyone's rights
and
um but I think we do need a leader who
can reflect the party's values and I
also think we need a leader who can also
carry the country
thank you
thank you Ash I'll come to the gentleman
the front here
just to say the order of answering this
thing would be Kate Ashley and Hamza
hello hello everybody uh just to
reassure the panel you are my friends
even if it doesn't sometimes feel like
that
my name is Paul Kirkwood I'm a member of
liverton North Branch in Edinburgh and
I'm a solicitor and I'm a mediator and I
help okay foreign
and that will be a second question for
all of you and my question says I'm not
going to ask you about your strategy for
getting Independence because you've been
asked that or you're feeling in the face
I'm sure she is the reverse one for you
the section 35 order with regard to the
grr bill is a good
and perfectly legal expression of power
involved being power and routine
at any time the Scotland Act of 1998
could be revoked by our Western
Government as a result of the doctrine
British parliamentary sovereignty
at a stroke discuss this problem that we
all fought so hard for
could be coming to an end just like that
and so the first question I'd like to
ask the whole panel is if such an event
were to come to pass
what would you do about that the second
much shorter question picking up on what
Kate said and this is back off the
office part of a moment there shopping
list is
Amazon stuff but I actually practice as
a mediator
I don't think Scott's got access to
Justice because it's too expensive for
most of us I have previously asked your
predecessor
to consider bringing forward a mediation
Act and the last Scottish Parliament
there was an attempt by a conservative
MSB who had broad cross-party support to
introduce that but it didn't come to
pass
I believe in part because of lack of
parliamentary time I'm an SMP member I
have been since 1984 I think that's
almost 30 years now
I would like the SNP to move forward
with the mediation act which will give
people in Scotland access to Justice in
an affordable and open manner so could
you address that as well please thank
you
just to be clear that all future
questions will be one question uh per
person but you've you've snaked in under
the radar
um first of all Kate thanks very much
because I'm very conscious I'm sitting
with two former Justice ministers so um
you should get a good answer tonight but
in terms of the first part of your
question I think you hit the nail on the
head
because we all want to defend Devolution
but if the soul aim or the sole limit of
our ambition is to defend Evolution we
are going to be on a losing Trend
because this UK government
will not stop
as far as I'm concerned in a rooting
Devolution now section 35 is just the
latest example but let's remember
section 30 where we've got multiple
mandates for another referendum and
that's not been granted and when it
comes to the gr bill which I know is not
the substance of your question but
that's not the first and it won't be the
last piece of legislation that the UK
government block so you know here's the
news that we all know the only defense
of laws in Scotland is Independence
ultimately we cannot rely long term on a
UK government to respect Evolution we
have got to deliver Independence and
that's why as I said in my opening
remarks the stakes are incredibly high
and I will fight harder for anyone
harder than anyone when it comes to
defending Scotland's rights I am one of
the few people that had to go head to
head with Rishi sunuk on a regular basis
during covet and one most of the time
didn't always win but the point is I
never stopped standing up for Scotland
when it came to Scot what was greatly
Scotland's
um in terms of the funding and the
financial position it's why I'm in
politics but I do want to say that you
know and I think the if the only route
possible to defending the section 35 is
going to court then I'll go to court but
I'd far rather we didn't just focus on
defending Devolution we focused on
making the case for Independence and to
make the case for Independence we have
got to be in campaigning mode we have
got to be making the case for
Independence Independence can't just be
an abstract constitutional term it's got
to be real for people we need to
demonstrate why Independence is not just
this thing it's about making the
difference to people's cost of living
crisis it's not just this thing it will
make the difference to poverty in
Scotland it's not just something out
there it's what will mean Scotland can
grow and prosper more successfully so an
independent government would need to
manage its fear as well
a devolved government needs to do that
whilst also campaigning for Independence
at the same time and that is all that
will defend ultimately at Devolution is
securing Independence so I'll Stand Up
on Devolution I will stand up and I will
fight but I tell you the only cast iron
guarantee on our laws is independence
and that must be our Focus as a party
first and foremost
thank you
thanks Kate now Ash thank you
thank you I'm so on the mediation first
yes there's a few former Justice
ministers on this panel this evening
um when I was in the Justice portfolio
we were certainly well aware of what
you're saying in terms of mediation and
we were there's various sort of
government initiatives that are trying
to promote that as something that should
be taken forward and I think that's
absolutely the right approach that we
should be doing so I was glad to see
that being taken forward and I you know
I'm sure that still is happening under
um Keith and Elena so in terms of you
know the parliament being closed down we
can definitely see that Westminster is
you know looking for all and every
Avenues to kind of thwart the Democratic
process in Scotland we know this and
they've been up to all sorts of things
and one of the sneakiest ones they've
been doing recently was this internal
markets act which means that many of the
pieces of legislation that we're seeking
to
um use in Scotland
um are now coming into conflict with
that when I was a minister I was trying
to pursue fireworks legislation and even
that was coming a crop with this
internal
in terms of how we held information and
how we were able to ask and retailers to
hold data and we weren't able to do this
we had to find a workaround which we did
do but it tends to make things a bit
more complicated than it's necessary to
do so I don't think they would
um you know seek to close the parliament
down I don't think quite frankly they
would get away with it but I think
that's why if we it's a bit like going
back to my analogy about treading water
I think if we if we tread water and
we're we're on the defense all the time
I think that's when you start to get
pushed back that's how I see it and so
in my opinion the best form of defense
is attack and that's why I want us to
move forward with uh more assertive if
you like strategy for Independence
so I think this process that we're going
through or we have been going through
over the last few few years now of
obviously winning elections and then
using that as a moral mandate if you
like to go and then ask Westminster you
know if we could have a section 30 order
to have an advisory referendum I mean
obviously we know that hasn't been
working so my view is why continue with
a process that isn't working we need to
reassess pivots and look to see if
there's another way we can go forward
with that so my view is that you know
the people of Scotland are sovereign we
don't need to ask the permission of
Westminster
thank you
and you know not many countries have
become independent through referendums
most of them have used The Ballot Box so
the referendum is not the gold standard
here
um you know Nicholas sturgeon Alex
salmon were only half right actually The
Ballot Box is the gold standard here and
so I want us to move to this permanent
mechanism of
um seeking to give that power back to
the Scottish people which is where it
belongs this is not about what
Westminster politicians have got to say
to Scotland or even you know what SNP
politicians have got to say this is
about the people of Scotland and what
they want to do and when they want to
govern themselves and I feel very sure
that that will be quite soon I looked up
and obviously I've been talking about
this
um you know they're getting the
Democratic mandate um a lot over the
last week so I looked up the figures
yesterday and actually in the regional
list vote in the last Scottish election
all the pro-independence parties
combined to a vote of 50.3 percent
so I think what that tells us is we are
very very close to being able to get
when a majority in the next election as
far as I'm concerned if we use the
process I'm suggesting We Are One
election away from Scotland choosing to
govern itself
[Applause]
thanks Ash and Hamza Paul well done for
two things first of all for getting to
the very nub of the issue and secondly
for managed to squeeze in two questions
that's well done because uh there's
always one Chancellor in the room and
please you have that you've managed to
do it this time around let me let me get
to the the mediation question first
because I think it's an excellent
question we've got great expertise
anybody who knows John sturrick for
example and the great work that John has
done knows about that arbitration knows
about mediation and I'd be happy to look
at the bell and because you're right
parliamentary time is what worked
against uh the member who brought that
bill forward so I'd be happy to look
because your your central premise is is
absolutely correct I think I can say
that in not overstepping The Mark with
the the current Justice secretary on
this panel but there is more we can do
with access to Justice no have snow
butts about that let me get to the the
central question you asked
for me the next first minister
absolutely has to fight against the
section 35 order no ifs no buzz because
that is the first time the section 35
Westminster veto has been used
can you imagine what signal it would
send what precedence it would say that
the first time Westminster uses section
35 to veto our legislation which by the
way remember was passed by a majority of
the parliament whether you agree or
disagree with grr actually is neither
here nor there it's about the principle
of Westminster being able to veto
legislation passed by a majority of the
parliament actually had support from
members of every single political party
if we cave in if the First Act of a new
first minister is to cave in to that
they will come after Bill after Bill
after Bill and we just can't allow it so
I give you an absolute unequivocal
guarantee
and and
an unequivocal guarantee that if I'm the
first minister of Scotland I will stand
up and I will challenge that secretary I
know I have snow bats no babies about it
and you know what I would do that if
it's a bill I disagreed with even if
it's a bill that has agreed with I would
be the first one to defend the
Democratic well of the Scottish
Parliament because if you can't defend
democracy under Devolution how on Earth
are people going to trust you to do it
but independent right so we've
absolutely got to do that first and
foremost and second thing I would say is
that the more and more Westminster
denied democracy the stronger our
support gets I'm I I slightly disagree
with Ash here that I could see
Westminster doing exactly as you
outlined because they are getting more
muscular in their approach more
aggressive in their approach and by the
way if we lay down in section 35 they
will feel emboldened and empowered so
that's why it's so important we don't
give them that opportunity
[Applause]
I'm just trying to make sure gender
balanced and the lady with is a glove
yes there you go
hot there you go
thank you I'm not exactly the tallest so
I had to find a strategy too
my name is Martha machuel I'm a City of
Edinburgh counselor and I'm a very proud
new Scott so you can see where this
question is going
we are 7.5 percent of the population of
Scotland and we chose Scotland as our
home and we are hopefully all 7.5 very
proud so my question has two parts sorry
it's not two questions two parts
hahaha
to be different so first part is I
remember on the last Manifesto for the
old redirection there was a promise to
look at the physical proof of the
settled status so what would you do if
you become
leader first Minister
the second question has to do with child
care because on top of being a new Scot
I'm also a single mom
so I have no family here to support me
the three of you are parents so you know
the challenge you go through and you
have Partners well I I think hash
doesn't he's more in a simulation
situation like me at the moment so I
have two young children being a
counselor being a mom the child care
does not take us into consideration so
we have spoken about child care it's
important for all the parents but what
would you do taking into account single
parents and new Scots and so many
families that don't have family
grandparents to help thank you
I'm not at all fooled by the idea saying
it's two parts
for Innovation just to say that if you
do ask two questions it means that
somebody else won't get the chance so
we'll try and stop that from now on but
it's up to you the candidates that they
want to answer and first of all we go to
Ash hello Marta
and Marta is a counselor in the area
that I represent in the eastern part of
the city
um so in terms of of settles data share
I mean we most I think a lot of people
obviously Scotland voted to stay in the
EU and I think many of us were very
dismayed I think it's some of the
messaging that was coming out of the UK
in terms of our EU citizens and the way
um that became such an issue and so I
think one of the one of the strong
reasons I think for Scotland becoming
independent is to be able to set our own
immigration policy
um and certainly to be back into the you
know the single market and have that
ability for people to come and settle in
the UK and for you know people from
Scotland to go and do likewise in in the
EU countries as well so I think that
definitely we would be looking for a
different system and we'd be looking for
one that um recognizes that we respect
and value people who come from you know
other European countries that want to
come here and work in our NHS work in
our Hospitality system and make that
easy for them so that they can feel
valued and this the system is feels like
it's a bit more welcoming in terms of
child care yeah I mean I remember this
I've got um twins myself which were um
let's just say they were quite a handful
when they were younger and they're grown
up now well sort of grown up their 19s
have just gone off to UNI so but I
certainly remember what that's like to
have you know Child Care issues and not
have a lot of family close by to help
not everyone does have that help I
totally understand that I was a bit in
that situation myself so we need to have
a system where you know families who
have young children feel like they're
supported you know so that they're able
to you know if they want to work full
time but they have that support so the
children are well looked after and
really good quality child care that is
going to develop that child give it
every opportunity that you know to get
the best absolute best start in life
it's so important so we need to work
towards that full level of child care
now we're doing really well on that I
think with the the 30 hours
um or the 22 hours if you want to have
that um through the year I know there
have been a few people said to me
there's a few issues in terms of how
that's implementing but I think we can
definitely improve on that and make that
work really well and and work to that
being more flexible and more wrap around
so that people are very supported
they've got the child care that they
need in order to do the other things
that they want to do as a family
thanks Ash and new Keat thanks very much
and we'll start with the child care one
because it's something that's
particularly in my mind at the moment
because although home base is is up in
the highlands that's a four and a half
hour drive and so when I'm working in
Edinburgh during the week I'm in
Edinburgh and it's me and baby seven
month old baby without the support the
the the infrastructure around me and
needing to to make that work and the SMP
has done a lot to invest in the
expansion of child care obviously
expanding it to three and four-year-olds
and vulnerable two-year-olds but that
still leaves for someone like myself and
perhaps for you that leaves two years
worth of child care which isn't
available for somebody with who doesn't
have that family support so I feel your
pain in terms of trying to get back into
work after being on maternity leave and
the challenge is there and I think
there's there's three things that we
probably need to do a lot more of the
first is ensuring that we are supporting
child care providers so that they are
they are able to provide the support and
there's a real mix you know child
minders will work for some people
private nurseries for someone else and
so on so that there is that that mix of
supporting the sector in the first place
to be there and available but secondly
it's financially so if a a a a a young
mother let's say is spending the
entirety of her salary and we know that
income levels are dropping income levels
have dropped because of inflation
spending the entirety of your salary on
child care with nothing left over then
you can't live so it makes you hugely
vulnerable as uh as a single mom and so
ensuring that there is that financial
support there and I think we do need to
look at how we provide additional
financial support when it comes to a
Mothers whose children are under the age
of a three would be the second thing and
then thirdly
with Independence we can do way more
because you look at many of the
Scandinavian countries that's what real
Child Care looks like that's what real
maternity cover looks like
um a country that has got
um wonderful provision when it comes to
uh you know extended maternity leave and
proper Child Care provision from a very
young age to allow mothers back into
work and we would need to have more
controls over our finances and and
Beyond but I think we can do and I think
that's one of the areas where we can
spell out the vision for people and
demonstrate that Independence isn't just
an abstract argument that some people
have who are interested in politics it's
about making the difference for example
to mothers who want to go back into work
my last uh point is just on on the first
a question that you asked welcome you
know Scotland has historically always
had a problem with immigration I love
the fact that people make Scotland their
home and we'd want that 7.5 to be higher
because we need more people
we need more people
and it is it is one of the marks of a
progressive country to be welcoming to
refugees Asylum Seekers and those who
want to make Scotland their home for a
whole host of different reasons and it
breaks my heart I find it devastating
that post-brexit we have these
requirements for more paperwork to prove
um that you are allowed to be here when
Scotland wants to welcome people into a
into this country so
you're welcome we will do all that we
can with devolved powers of making
Scotland an attractive place we will do
all that we can to make that case
internationally please come to Scotland
and before we're independent we can
start planning for Independence and how
we make it a far more attractive
immigration approach
thanks Kate and Hamza oh man the problem
I'm asking the question third is they
give that good answers you know but let
me let me try to let me try to build
upon what's been said uh Marta thank you
for the question I'll also start with
the child care uh issue of very
pertinent to to me too I've got a
three-year-old
um and a 13 I've got I've got a three
major and a teenager I've also got a 13
year old with a three-year-old uh I
think one person clap thanks mum
um I've got I've got a three-year-old
and and we couldn't do what we do
without uh that important child care and
for me three things that we should do so
my my Flagship first announcement that I
made or one of the first I should say
announcements I made when I launched my
campaign was that if I am first minister
of Scotland uh as first minister of
Scotland I would accelerate the
expansion of child care to one and
two-year-olds in my first budget because
it's so so important for not just you
Marta for people right up and down
country who desperately need that
assistance and why do they need it and
why is that when when it's a win for
them and it's a win for our economy as
well and to me that is the center that
is the ethos of the well-being economy
that we ensure that fairness opportunity
is at the heart of building that economy
and that economy not just for the sake
of gleaming profits but actually to to
reinvest back into the people so Child
Care is so important for that so first
thing is accelerate uh the expansion of
child care in the first budget if I'm uh
first Minister second thing would be to
work with the pvi sector because there
is an issue around Equitable funding
I've spoken to enough Nursery owners
providers the pvi sector who tell me
they need a more Equitable Funding
Solution so I would look at to do that
with immediacy and the third thing that
I I introduced or said I would introduce
is first Minister if I'm elected would
be a helping hand fund so that'd be a
500 500 pound loan at two parents that
they wouldn't have have to pay until
their child exited child care and it
would help with those initial upfront
costs because we know parents have those
initial upfront costs not all of them
can afford it because they've been off
work of course and so we'd give them the
the 500 pounds to help with that initial
upfront cost so that's the things I
would look to do because if we're
serious about not just reducing poverty
but eradicating poverty then doing all
we can to help people particularly women
get into work it'll be better for
everybody
um the second uh or the first question
uh you asked I agree with a lot of what
my colleagues here are saying I don't
know
if you like me had The Misfortune of
watching prime minister's questions this
week but it was one of the most
disgusting exchanges I have ever seen
between the Prime Minister uh Tori prime
minister and frankly a peer limitation
over Tory prime minister Rick here
stammer where they were trying to out
muscle each other on who Could Turn Back
refugees from the UK disgusting
despicable abhorrent
and goes against everything we as a
party dare I say everything we as a
nation stand for and you know immigrants
new Scots have given us so much to this
country through Academia through
business
through their Cuisine thank goodness for
it you know they've had they've enriched
us as a country and as a nation and
we've got to be welcoming and
it's absolutely right helps our economy
too the amount of people the amount of
business
businesses the amount of staff that is
acquired in our public sector that we
could benefit from from that uh inward
migration and and the second thing the
last thing I'll say on this is I am
unashamedly unapologetically European
and we must rejoin the European Union as
quickly as we possibly can as an
independent nation
and I can't wait I can't wait for the
day that Edinburgh is an independent
European Capital uh as part of an
independent Scottish
independent Scotland
and for that we can't set off with
anything less can't settle for after
can't set up for anything else we have
to make sure we rejoin the European
Union uh and and now uh last thing
absolute last thing so I keep seeing
lasting absolute last thing I'll see is
that is why I took a slightly different
approach to to Nicola in that uh respect
the reason why she mentioned the de
facto referendum I wouldn't take it off
the table entirely I think we should
discuss that but for me one of the
reasons why it's not my preferred option
is because it disenfranchises uh
European citizens from voting and you
know particularly after brexit we've got
huge amounts of support from our
European citizens so that's one of the
reasons why I've distanced myself
slightly uh from that approach
[Applause]
mentioned being the third person to
answer I can just say the next order is
according to the smp's question
randomizer a very sophisticated piece of
equipment it will be Hamza Ash and Kate
for this question
um gentlemen at the front
hi Adam e Banji from Edinburgh Central
I'm going to break a trend and try and
keep to the rules with regard to
questions
um I think most people agree that we're
not getting to independence without
significant support from people who
presently think we're barking mad right
and so my question to all three of you
is
what pitch
can you make to no voters
that you think distinguishes you
from your colleagues
thank you Adam and Hamza
actually I suspect that there is a lot
that unites us on this uh question
because for me as I said this in my
opening contribution Adam was an
excellent question is we've got to get
off this issue of process I'm not saying
we don't discuss process is important
and we've got to find a a process to get
us to where we need to get to but it is
going to come when Independence becomes
that consistent majority of you and to
do that we have to provide a vision so
we have to first of all govern well and
I think we've got a good track record to
build upon but we've got to govern well
we've got to have the best people in
government we've got to show what we can
do with Devolution so people believe
that when it comes to Independence my
goodness we could do even more uh on top
to build upon Devolution so first of all
govern and govern well secondly we need
to be ambitious what was what was the
spirit of 2014 the spirit of 2014 was
hope over fear in a nutshell this whole
over fear and we need to give people
Hope by God people need hope
and we've got to see and be ambitious
it's not about reducing poverty I want
to eradicate poverty I want to be bold
on land reform I want to make sure that
when it comes to Renewables for example
I want to unleash the green potential of
this country 77
000 jobs in the green economy that can
be Unleashed you know we do that we
don't just lease off our Renewables we
should take a equity stake we should
make sure that our profits come back to
the people not just remain we're
shareholders
we have to tackle and reform land in
this country is in the hands of too few
people it has to be in the hands of most
of us
so if I'm being honest and really
truthful with you Adam
almost 16 years in government we've got
to re-energize and find that bold
radical Spirit that's made so many
people vote for us still vote for us and
build upon the Legacy so the vision is
to inspire I could say 101 things but
what I think we could do with
Independence don't worry Keith I want I
said 101 but we've got to absolutely get
out there and there's no shortcut Adam
we've got to speak to every single
person on every single doorstep we're
going to win this if we go City by City
Town by Town Village by Village doorstep
by doorstep we do that then I promise
you we win our independence we only do
it when we Inspire with a positive
division
Ash
so I think we need to obviously you know
it's not a radical suggestion to suggest
that we need to build support I think we
all accept that we need to do that but I
just also want to put in the caveat as
well that we need to make sure we keep
the support we already have
because we don't want to get into
position where people feel you know that
they're maybe being taken for granted or
that we've moved away from from
positions that people supported and that
you know we lose that support so I think
that's very important my view on that um
you know so I was campaigning full-time
in the yes campaign in the run-up to the
vote in 2014 and had a lot of
conversations with people my view on
that is there were there was a
significant number of people I I
couldn't quantify that for you but it
was definitely a significant number of
people who who in their heart wanted to
vote Yes and they wrestled with it
really quite hard but in the end there
was just something that held them back
you know there was there was a couple of
issues and and you um in the room will
know exactly what I'm talking about
where we didn't quite manage to make
that case well enough you know there was
a couple of issues so they were a bit
nervous so we could need to do better on
that this time around and so what I'm
suggesting which I believe is different
from my fellow it's here is that if we
set up this commission and we task it
with making the case in terms of
preparing and planning and setting up
the infrastructure so we would start if
I become first Minister we will start
work on that immediately on day one I
will set up this commission and they
will start planning and preparing and
getting this ready
so I'll give you an example of one of
the issues that I felt was a key
Battleground in 2014 and that we perhaps
were not able to win that argument we
weren't able to give people the Comfort
on that issue was currency and many
people will know what I'm talking about
and that was that was the one issue I
did Street Soul after Street Soul after
Street stall and that was
um that was the one issue I don't know
if anyone remembers Alex salmon having
that debate with Ulster darling that
first one and it didn't go very well no
and that was that the next morning I was
on a street store and that was the first
and only time I can shouted out in the
street was about currency they were
shouting at me in the street you know
Plan B and all that you know so we
definitely could have made a better
argument on that one so I think if we
can set up everything to do with the
currency as much as we can under the
evolution then we continue the planning
set up the Central Bank while we're
doing the negotiations to leave the UK
then at the time that we become
independent we can move to that new
currency within weeks
and the reason I know we can do that is
because other European countries have
done this so you can go and and have a
look at that there's information out
there on the other countries that have
done it the quickest one was one month
and seven days that one country did it
so it's amazing what can be done and I
think that will give people the
confidence that they need in order to
say right I'm not worried about that now
because I can see Scotland's made the
planning we've had the we've had the
discussion we've won the argument and
then we can move on and the the other
thing that I think um is different about
me is I want to set the wider movement
free I want them to go off and I want to
bring back the absolute best that we had
during the yes campaign and because I
was in it and I saw it and that
Grassroots campaign was awesome so we
need to bring that back and in the
convention they can they can work on
that themselves this will be totally
separate from government you know as it
should be out in Civil Society people
getting on with that and I want them to
co-design that campaign and way I
envisage that is that they will use that
campaign design the messaging to build
relationships with people to have the
conversations with people about the
things that are important to them and
move them gradually in their position
from no to yes so I think I've got a
unique plan here I think it's got all
the elements that we need I've thought
about it really carefully in order to
get us from where we are now into
Scotland and becoming a member of the
United Nations
thanks Ash and Kate thanks very much
well I think this is probably one of the
most important questions that the SMP
needs to be grappling with right now
which is again as I said in my opening
remarks ironic because it's not about
convincing all of us it's about how we
reach out to those who are not part of
our movement and before I come on to
really answering your question which was
what might I offer can I also say that I
think there is it needs to be addressed
as a team you know I have two for
example exceptional colleagues on either
side of me both of whom have unique
skills talents experiences when it comes
to reaching new voters you know Hamza is
in a league of his own when it comes to
communicating and reaching out to people
and persuading people Ash has a Clarity
of vision which I think is exceptional
and ultimately when it comes to
persuading people we're only going to do
it as a team and all of us have
different skills abilities backgrounds
we've got lawyers in the room we've got
people from all walks of life and we are
the ones that are going to shape their
vision and the message to convince
people and then we're the ones that are
going to use our contacts our friends
our family to persuade them to directly
answer your question what can I bring
I think the fault lines
run along the economic arguments
and if there's one thing I think I can
do it's about making the economics real
for people
so we hear jurors figures battered
around and you know there's a lot of
debate about them but actually not often
do you hear people getting in and about
them and underneath them when it comes
to the general public you know how many
people know that 70 of the revenue
raised in jurors is determined by the UK
government forty percent of the spend is
determined by the UK government and yet
they use that as an argument to show why
Scotland can't afford to be independent
it shows precisely why it's gotten
camped afford not to be independent so
on on all the infrastructure about the
economy we need an answer but more than
that we ultimately need to show how
Scotland can be wealthier feeder Greener
because here's the deal there's other
independent countries that don't have
half the resources that we have but are
wealthier why is that because they're
not Shackled on old-fashioned
Westminster economic model so that's the
that's that's what I think I can offer
so much Kate
[Applause]
time to get some gender balance again
hey the lady just over here
hello I'm Hazel Godfrey from fourth
Branch Edinburgh
in 2018
Scotland produced the sustainable growth
commissioned report
and became a founding member of the
well-being economy governments
following Independence which one of
these Economic Development Pathways
should Scotland follow
and why
thank you very much uh the order this
time
the order this team is Kate Hamza the
nice so over to you again Kate great the
well-being of being are going to be
approached tonight that because there
has been a lot of international interest
in that pioneering initiative the
well-being economy governments
initiative which was set up by ourselves
in partnership with two other
governments has attracted attention from
across the world so people have I can
think of of the Canadian government for
example I've had sit-down meetings over
the phone with the representatives of of
Canadian governments to talk about what
we're doing to further the well-being
economy and how we're using our budgets
differently and I love that because we
don't need to wait to be independent to
be pioneering when it comes to the
well-being economy and for me at the
very heart of my Approach my pitch uh
the the vision I have for Scotland is
the well-being economy which is you have
a prosperous economy
but the prosperity is not the purpose
the prosperity is a means of eradicating
poverty and this is not about
trickle-down economics this is about
creating well-paid secure jobs across
Scotland whether you're in the Hebrides
you're in Shetland or you're in Selkirk
we create well-paid secure jobs with
strong terms and conditions that make
work pay so that people who are in work
can actually afford to live unlike the
situation we have right now where
inflation is eating away at wages people
are doing three jobs and they still
can't afford their bills so the
well-being economy which we've already
been pioneering needs to be built or
needs to be expanded because bear in
mind most of the macroeconomic levers
are still in Westminster
but where we have been able to shift and
we have done so already and I think
there's a lot further that we can go
Prosperity eradicating poverty Public
Services that's the triumvirate that's
the triangle and that is our Focus needs
to be our Focus as a government
thanks Kate and Hamza
I think the sustainable growth
commission's out of date I think it's
it's not the approach I would take the
well-being economy is absolutely the
approach we have to take uh Unapologetic
about that great work that's been done
by I believe in Scotland I think they're
an excellent organization uh Gordon
McIntyre Temple camp and others who've
been involved they had a pullout last
week if you saw it an excellent poll
that showed if we Center our economic
approach and the wellbeing economy
support for Independence goes up and
consistently stays in the mid 50s I'm
ambitious I want to go even further than
that but it's a pretty good uh Place uh
to be and for me that is a that the
heart of that well-being economy
approach an economy that works for the
people as opposed to the other way
around that fairness happiness health
they are given as much weight need more
weight than economic growth economic
growth for a purpose and we do that it
goes back to Adam's question we do that
then we inspire people
doesn't have to be the way it is at the
moment you know I remember and I'm a
Luigi at Heart Of course that what Jimmy
Reed said
rat races are for rats right we're not
we need to get off that rat race we need
to say to people that actually you need
to work for a purpose
um not just to to to work ourselves uh
to the Bone and there's great work also
being done that has already been done by
Sean Robinson Neil gray and the fairness
and Social Justice Commission I
recommend that work
um to anybody that wants to take a look
and I agree that we can demonstrate what
we mean by a well-being economy right
now of course we could do so much more
with the powers of independence of that
there's just simply no doubt but we can
demonstrate now and one of the things
that again I am Unapologetic about
unashamed of who is that I plant my flag
down on the on the path of progressive
taxation I absolutely believe that if
you earn more you must pay more and if
you earn more and pay more
then that's what if you take 23 24 under
under John Sweeney's most recent budget
in 23 24 what he's done by doing that
and which carries by the way popular
support is that allows a billion pounds
more to come into the Health Service
that's a billion pounds that we spend in
paying our nurses our Porters our
paramedics and everybody in the Health
Service fairly so yep absolutely grow
the economy I agree with that we
absolutely have to ensure we give as
much support to help those who are
economically inactive into work not
creating jobs and demanding they go into
work and all giving them the support
around Child Care smart has already said
giving them as much support holistic
support to get them into work and we're
doing some of that but do not ever
succeed any ground when it comes to
progressive taxation
[Applause]
and Ash
yeah I'd agree I think the the growth
commission model I think things have
really moved on from from when that
report came out things do move quite
fast in terms of
um the position on the you know the
economic case so definitely the
well-being economy for me as well and
you know we have to remember economies
are not for the government economies are
for the people in the country and so we
need an economy that works for everyone
um so we need well-paid jobs you know we
have to remember that
um many of the families where the
children are living in poverty these
children have parents who are in work so
work isn't paying enough for people at
the moment or many people in Scotland to
be able to put a roof over their
children's heads feed it and clothe them
that is completely unacceptable so we
need to move on from that model so we
need well-paid jobs for people where
they're able to have an appropriate
work-life balance where they're being
paid enough that they can look after
their families and we also need to be
able to protect our environment as well
so that it's a clean and healthy place
for everyone to live and that's one of
the reasons I want Scotland to be
independent there's absolutely no point
um being an independent country if we're
just going to be exactly the same as we
are as part of the UK we want to be more
ambitious we want the country to be a
better place to live we want it to be
fairer and Greener and a nicer place to
live and we know that countries where
the levels of inequality are more
pronounced are not good places to live
we can see that where it's measured by
the Ginny coefficient where there's much
lower levels of of
um income inequality and those the
people it's nicer places to live people
are happier it's just more pleasant all
around and we can see that and some of
our neighboring countries so I want um I
want Scotland to have that I want us to
work towards that I want us to all feel
like we're part of an economy that is
delivering for the people that live in
Scotland
hey thanks Ash just to see the next
order of Anthony Hamza Kate then Ash
I've been trying to make sure it's
gender balanced and from the front and
the back but I've forgotten the sides so
I'm going to go to Joe who has always
just cut my just over here sure
thank you chair and thank you for
effectively chairing such a good debate
this evening my name is Professor Joe
goldblad I'm with the Edinburgh Central
Branch and
I think we can all agree how lucky we
are to have such talented candidates
thank you for stepping forward
I have one question chair and my
question is simply this in all the
previous hustings which I've observed
when we ask our candidates questions
they say well I'd like to make three
points
I'm going to seek a fourth point from
you this evening
and the fourth point is because you're
all parents as I'm now a grandfather
what might you say to your wee bands in
fact to jock tamsin's Barons all of us
about how you would like us to behave in
the early days of a new country so that
Scotland becomes In Our Lifetime the
greatest small nation on Earth what do
you expect of us thank you
question from a true Professor
um Hamza you're the first or what
question from uh Professor Goldblatt and
a true internationalist of our movement
as well so we're actually lucky to have
Joe as part of the Party part of the
movement
and uh really grateful to him for asking
that question that's not gonna be
sucking up for your vote by the way
genuinely uh know the good work that
you've done uh for me and
congratulations on becoming a
grandfather too what great uh news uh as
well though can I say on behalf of
parents everywhere to their Grant to
their to their own parents the
grandparents of their children can you
stop giving them so much sugar and then
handing them back to us that is not I
know it's your prerogative but I think I
can speak for Kate and I in particular
it's it's it makes life Bloody difficult
right anyway let's let's um get to the
substance of your question we should be
acting now as though we're in the early
days of a new nation and if people look
know how we Act
what our values are then they will be
confident that when it comes to
Independence that we will care for all
of our citizens and that's why I think
it's so important
but Nicola first Minister's questions
was unequivocal
in her support for refugees and Asylum
seekers in sharp contrast to the
inhumane policies of a UK government who
are willing to turn away people in their
desperate ever of need and for me what I
want us to do
and what we've got to do when we take
the the vision of Independence to the
doorsteps
is respect and empathize with no voters
respect and empathize we're not going to
win them over by shouting at them we're
not going to win them over by haranguing
them not going to win them over by
telling them they're stupid for not
believing in Independence we're going to
win them over if we truly understand why
they're voting no what is it that makes
them want it what's the fears how do we
address those fears what about the
British identity what is it that makes
them want to stay within the union and
how do we make sure that is what we tap
into to try to reassure them and
persuade them and on the day we get
independence the day we win a referendum
and is coming soon on The Daily when I
referendum the very first thing I would
do as first Minister when we win that
referendum
is reach out to our no voters and say
you are part of our independent nation
you are just as vital as anybody who
voted yes you are a fabric of our
society and we are going to go on this
journey together whether you voted yes
or whether you voted no and I think
that's going to be really important and
the approach we take to win people over
to Independence
foreign
country I want to act as to act as
though we believe in ourselves
because we will only become independent
when we believe in ourselves and success
is not inevitable we need to believe in
ourselves so the same message as I will
be sharing with my daughter as she grows
up will be the message I want to
communicate to every citizen in the
first day of an independent Scotland
believe in yourself you are smart enough
talented enough wealthy enough creative
enough you have a track record a
Heritage a culture a history which you
should be proud of and no country at the
point of becoming independent will have
been as wealthy and successful as
Scotland will be when we become
independent but to reach New Heights
it's really simple we Scots we think
humility is a virtue and it is but you
know what so is self-confidence
foreign
[Applause]
to follow
um what what do I say to my children
about how we want to be I I like to
think that we're all here to love to
learn and to grow and I think that would
apply equally to a country as it does to
an individual that we should treat
others with respect and we should go
towards things that we find exciting but
also a little bit scary I think that
applies to the country as well I'd also
like to say that I think
um Scotland might like to have a
constitution that we might like to
develop a constitution that we might
like to crowdsource that Constitution
and that it would reflect codify and
showcase the values that we hold dear in
Scotland and in that new country of a
New Scotland
thanks Ash and
um I'll go to the other side the lady
just over here
thank you very much Deputy leader for
noticing me
um my name is Catherine Wooldridge I am
from Dundee West Branch and I promise I
have quickly condensed a three question
um
into one question
um the Butte house agreement with the
green party has been a success but I
have heard some candidates see that the
green party won't work with them please
explain why that is as I think it's your
responsibility to ensure that the Butte
house agreement continues as partis as
part of your effort to provide good
governance and to unify the YES Movement
thank you very much oh oh
thank you
thank you very much the fact that the
first place I sued for Lexington was
Dundee West is no indication of bias I
just it just caught my eye
um so it's going to be Kate Ashton Hamza
so Kate great well prior to the house
agreement
the level of stress every year to get a
budget through was enormous and the
ViewHouse agreement made budget process
or easier and a lot more focused on the
issues where we could jointly unite so
if there's anybody who a valued the
Butte house agreement but B had
experience of negotiations with the
greens it's me
and I think that more generally to win
independence we've got to work with
organizations groups and parties that
all share our objective when it comes to
Independence
one of the the the sort of a
values of the Butte house agreement
though is that it aligned our joint
efforts where we agreed and identified
areas that were excluded so one of those
areas that was excluded was of course
economic growth and economic Prosperity
now I think from Scotland's perspective
right now there's a lot more that we
could do when it comes to economic
prosperity in terms of the well-being
economy there's well-being which is
really important but there's also the
economic part so we do need to see more
growth not least when our economy grew
by 0.1 percent uh last quarter so the
point I've made when it comes to the
Butte house agreement is that I would
like to continue to work with the greens
and I think we need to look at how to
ensure we can work with the fact that
I'm so Keen that we focus on our
economic potential focus on economic
Prosperity really unlock the potential
of key Industries because I think that
Prosperity element is vital in fact it's
almost non-negotiable if we're serious
about eradicating poverty and
reinvesting in our public services so my
Approach has been I've always worked
well with them Keen to continue to work
but I have got a focus on economic
Prosperity which I think is really
critical really critical to the people
of Scotland and those kids in poverty
that I talked about at the beginning and
if we can find a way of continuing to
work together whilst maintaining that
focus on economic Prosperity then I'm
sure whoever's Finance secretary will
continue to enjoy budgets a lot more
than I used to
thanks Kate uh Ash thank you
our Coalition Partners in government
right now and obviously as candidates
were all being asked you know what do we
think of that would we continue it and I
actually think it's probably not
appropriate to be giving answers in
media interviews about whether that
should continue or not that's a
conversation to have face to face with
our green Partners in a mature grown-up
way to have that conversation and
obviously there have been some media
reports that you're alluding to where um
the green party members themselves are
saying that they might have issues with
the leadership of certain candidates
that's obviously a decision for the
green party themselves
um I think we well I actually tried to I
did call the greens a couple of days ago
when I was reaching out to all the the
pro-independence party leaders and I've
yet to get a return call back but I'll
keep trying to see if I can
um get to speak to them you know in
terms of The Wider movement they're
obviously they're very important to that
conversation and you know I would really
hope that they would be part of the
independence convention working
alongside people of no party all the
other different parties as part of the
wider movement but in terms of of
government you know there are obviously
areas where we're very closely aligned
with the greens on on some things but
there are other areas where we're not so
aligned and we've had a couple of years
of that agreement now and I wonder if
maybe this might be something that the s
p membership at large might like to have
a discussion on to see how it's working
for everyone so I would certainly want
to speak to the greens see if we're able
to continue it the relationship and see
if that might be possible
[Applause]
thanks Ash and Hamza can I just remind
everybody
that 95 of our membership endorsed the
boot house agreement with the greens
so
any candidate who is talking about
listening to our membership has to
listen to 95 of a membership
um whoever wins this leadership contest
is not going to get 95 of the votes and
guarantee you that so it's about
listening to we should have
self-confidence it's true but let's be
let's be let's be realistic right so 95
of a membership voted for that boot
house agreement so for me I uh I I just
will leave you know not with Once until
out of doubt that to me that deal with
the greens is worth its weight in gold
absolutely worth its weight in gold the
reason why is because yep we've been in
minority government before but I'm
telling you now sitting in that chamber
as I do it is one of the most toxic
environments from our opposition can you
imagine that the First Act of a new
first minister of the SNP is to wrap up
a deal and reject our green partners and
you'd have to rely on Douglas Ross or
Anna sarwar to pass our budget madness
madness for any SMP leader to even
contemplate doing that
and you know I'm sorry it's not for a
new leader to come in and start to
unpick a house agreement that was agreed
by 95 of our membership to say that we
now want to insert economic Prosperity
but it's the well-being economy that
they believe in and that we believe in
and so to unpick that and to damage that
relationship won't just cause us
difficulty in the Scottish Parliament I
promise you it will have Ripple effects
for councils up and down the country so
I have huge impacts and huge effects
right across the country so
um I am saying uh as I say without in
order that I don't leave you with that
asintella and iota of Doubt whatsoever
as first minister
I would honor that agreement I would
honor our membership I would want to
strengthen that pro-independence
majority in Parliament and I'm a unifier
I want to make sure I reach out to the
entire movement you can't do that if you
reject and disregard the second largest
independence party in the country
okay let's see we spoke before with a
candidates we've agreed that the last
question will be wrapped up with her
concluding the marks as well so this
will be the last question but it will
also be a chance for the candidates to
make their final pitch
um can I see the gentleman at the back
he's got I think he's got a beard it's
my eyesight apologies
you just looked around the person the
person has just looked around that's you
yeah thanks very much I'm Robert and I'm
from Peasley branch
when it comes to the currency Union
you're talking about it
um
may not in
um currencies and I looked at Asian
financial crisis where it started right
so I thought that what you were saying
was absolutely dead on
um I campaigned in Edinburgh I
was passionate about I then
um was angry and disappointed that we
lost our referendum I think created all
under one Banner to take the you know to
create a marching movement so I was part
of that they created that
what made me doing that was this was
Elizabeth the connoissean from the no
campaign
um on the 2nd of February 2014 Andrew
Bailey who's now the governor of like
England he was uh when the Scottish
Affairs site committee
all right this chip but I think it was
Ian Davidson and he said these words
we will be all ended our last resort to
Scottish government you just have to see
what happened to Iceland without
regulatory support
and that was on the channel
parliamentary channel number 81.
I didn't record that but what I thought
I'd do is I'll get a BBC iPlayer
and BBC iPlayer if you can be quiet just
now please and BBC iPlayer what they've
done it's the
doesn't
broadcaster
now what I've done something for the
transcript
okay
yeah okay so Ash is addressed earlier on
but I didn't hear much about it in terms
from
Kate or Hamza I mean can you explain how
you would advance that concept
okay I can say that just to repeat the
point that to the order here is Ash
Hamza and Kate and Ash will have the
chance as well to as each of the
candidates will to give some concluding
remarks as well as address the question
thank you very much over to you thank
you okay thank you yes I agree I think
there's about 200 countries in the world
and only four of them don't have their
own currency uh one of those I think it
was Moldova needed to go to the IMF for
a bailout during covid
um you need to have control over your
own monetary policy in order to run your
economy and to make a success of being
an independent country
and we haven't been talking about it we
haven't been making the case we haven't
been talking about the currency we're
not moving things forward I think we
probably there's been more in the media
about the idea of an independent
Scottish currency in the last couple of
weeks because I've been talking about it
then we've probably talked about it in
the last couple of years and I think
it's really important we need to
normalize that idea for people in
Scotland that you know moving to another
currency is normal and it's what will
lead to Scotland becoming successful and
it's nothing to be afraid of and in my
opinion we should be doing that now not
waiting until the run-up to the next
election or the next referendum or
however that goes and I think that
making the case for that now also shows
a confidence in preparing for
Independence winning that argument and
that Scotland will go on to be very
successful it's so super important
waiting you know using the pounds like
we said we were going to last time
allows our opponents to use that
political leverage exactly the same way
that they did last time and it's also a
crazy experiment on the Scottish economy
that no one else would take the risk
with quite frankly we we need to move to
our new currency as soon as possible so
um I won't say any more about that but I
think I do have if anyone's interested I
think I have with me and some mock-ups
of a possible Scottish currency the
designs from the Scottish currency group
so if anyone wants to have a look at
them they can come and talk to me about
them later but in summary as we're
finishing up this evening I just want to
say to you all that I don't accept that
um Westminster has a veto on the views
of the Scottish people so that is the
thank you that is that is how I'm
approaching this I want to be assertive
I want to give the people of Scotland
back the power to choose their own
future I believe I have a plan to get us
to Independence so I think we either
settle for Devolution or we fight on
towards independence and I would like to
be your leader to fight on towards
independence thank you
thank you Kate and Hamza sorry thank you
Ash and Hamza
thanks very much
um first and foremost uh for me I will
say that I absolutely believe this
Scotland should have its own currency no
I have snow but no maybes are slight
differences here uh that we don't
actually have the legal power to create
our own central bank so that doesn't
exist at the moment so we've got to work
through a transition now that will upset
some people who will say I want it and I
want it quick and trust me I want it as
quickly as we possibly can but we've
already heard actually from Ash herself
quite rightly to say that we're people's
fears are and around currency and around
pensions and therefore we've got to take
people with us on this journey and to do
that we've got to be absolutely credible
in what we're putting forward in terms
of our plan for currency so for me we've
got a paper on currency we've seen the
Scottish government's perspective it's
on uh on that particular issue what's
really important is that we get that
prospectus into bite-sized chunks and
get it to our activists because you can
disarm those who give false arguments
about the currency and this actually
takes me to a slightly wider point which
is I think in the SNP if I'm being frank
an honest and I'm within the Scottish
government we're too slow about
rebutting some of the nonsense that
comes from the opposition and that comes
from
and that comes from certain sections of
the media so one of the first things I
would do as leader of the SNP would be
to make sure we have that instant
rebuttal unit not one that sends out a
press release two days later one day
it's already you know the the LIE is
already halfway around the world the
true thing got its pants on right so
we've got to make sure uh I don't I
don't make up that phrase by the way uh
for the one for Paul who seems to enjoy
it
um so I I think we have to have that
instant rebuttal unit that counteracts
some of the lies and they will tell lies
about the currency they will tell lies
and disinformation about every single
part of our perspectives so for me
absolutely Scottish currency get there
as soon as we possibly can there's got
to be our transition period because
we've got to set up the institutions uh
in advance but as soon as we can
absolutely have that Independence
independent currency
um for me I'm not going to give you the
whole pitch you've heard that already
you've heard it throughout the course of
the day I just wanted to reiterate what
I said at the beginning
that I think the job for you to choose
the next leader of the SNP has got to be
somebody you believe that can Inspire
because we're going to win independence
by inspiring people with the vision for
Independence it's got to be somebody
that you believe that can keep our
support and then grow our support and
unify right across the movement
and it's got to be somebody who of
course can govern and govern well I
think all of my colleagues uh absolutely
can do that and I hope you believe uh
that I could do that as well and then
who is it that's going to be with you
shoulder to shoulder who's going to
stand with you whether it's in the
rallies whether it's trapping the doors
whether it's leading from the front and
I want to be able to do that but not as
a leader alone in the SNP we have huge
amounts of talent right across the
entire party I I've been with pride on a
Wednesday afternoon when Stephen Flynn
tears him apart in Westminster
but he's blooming good as well I have to
say
um and tears I'm a part of Westminster
and we've got great talent and local
government hundreds of councils up and
down the country who are doing an
amazing job at the front line
or of course excellent colleagues in the
Scottish Parliament as well and amongst
the wider membership we've got to
harness that Talent Nick Lo and she
stood down I was gutted absolutely got
it but you know what it's also an
opportunity where new faces can come to
the front where we can re-energize that
movement and I give you my promise
you're stuck with me
whatever happens I'm a son of this party
my dad joined in 74. I've been a member
for almost 20 years I hope to win I
wouldn't be in the contest if I didn't
think I could win it but if I don't I
promise you this whoever is our leader
I'll be standing behind the 100
thanks samsa and Kate
thanks very much well Scotland will move
to its own currency my view is that it
needs to do that at a time that is right
because what's most important in the
first few days of Independence is having
a stable economy it's that stability
that will keep the bills paid it's that
stability that will ensure the wages are
paid and it's that stability that will
actually make the difference to Scotland
being a wealthier feeder and Greener
country and we do then move to our own
currency when the time is right and you
know Scotland will be independent the
path ahead though is one that we are all
debating And discussing at this point in
time because we're at uh we're at a
Crossroads and what we need to focus on
is that clear re-energized vision for
the future we need to look again at how
we persuade those who aren't yet
persuaded
and apart from anything else we need to
keep being a team
and unity is not uniformity you can have
the space for debate and discussion
because we need to be in discussion to
ensure that we get the best ideas
but we're ultimately all United were
United
in line with that one goal that's what I
said at the outset and that's what I
want to finish on we are united when it
comes to that goal of delivering
Independence and I think the next leader
needs to build on the Legacy Legacy that
we have and go further the next leader
needs to take the fight to the
opposition it needs to take the fight to
labor it needs to take the fight to the
Tories we've got the labor leader up in
Scotland today we need to take them on
and we will win
but the next leader also needs to be
able to reach out to no voters who may
not have a say in this contest and won't
necessarily be voting for The SNP right
now but we want them to vote for
Independence and I think they can be
persuaded they can be persuaded with the
right case the right vision and the
right approach and the last thing we
need from a leader is a leader who can
govern well who sees their job as yes
standing up for devil you should
absolutely but never been content to
only defend Devolution and instead will
use Devolution to ensure we serve the
people of this country because the
reason that we keep winning is because
the people trust us they trust us to
have their best interests at heart they
trust us to do whatever we can to serve
them and their interests and they trust
us to take them into the future we need
more people to trust us because we need
more people to support not just the
party winning elections that's important
but to win that critical key election
the D that Scotland chooses to believe
in itself and become independent we're
there we believe in ourselves we believe
we can be feeder wealthier and Greener
and we need to persuade more people the
independence is not an abstract concept
Independence is the route to eradicating
Poverty to being a prosperous country
and to being feeder and one day we'll
get there and one day we'll be looking
back
five years into independent celebrating
our fifth Independence Day
10th Independence Day 20th independency
and those in the dim and distant future
will be celebrating 100 Years of
Independence it's coming yet it's coming
soon and we're gonna get there if we go
together thanks
you very much my apologies that we
couldn't get more questions and blame
those who sneaked in two questions at
the start
um but thanks very much and also can I
also thank the candidates for a really
Collegiate excellent discussion if I can
[Applause]